a key member of the family will be
missing from the latest installment in
the Fast and Furious franchise Dwayne
the rock Johnson who has portrayed Luke
Hobbs in the series ever since 2011 s
Fast Five will be sitting out the action
when the latest entry hits theaters this
summer given his rocky history with
franchise star Vin Diesel and the
success of last year's spinoff Fast and
Furious presents Hobson sure fans could
be forgiven for thinking that Johnson
might be going his own way however that
doesn't appear to be the case in a 2019
interview with mtv news
johnson explained that his absence from
f 9 was due to scheduling conflicts with
hobbes ensure an explanation which
seemed a little suspect at the time the
spin-off flicker just erupted and when
asked by the interviewer if he and
co-star Jason Statham will be taking
part in the ninth film in the main
series Johnson hemmed and hawed he said
the plan has always been for the vasa
viewers universe to grow and expand as
of now we're not in fast 9 because
they're getting ready to start shooting
we suppose that even the rock needs to
take a breather from action movies every
once in a while still considering that
his work on Hobson sure was complete and
f9 was gearing up to enter production at
the time of the interview it sure seems
like he could have participated perhaps
a dancer wasn't quite the whole truth
it's well documented that Johnson and
diesel butted heads and possibly biceps
during the making of 2017 s fate of the
Furious what we still don't know the
exact nature of the beef we do know that
it was serious enough that a2 didn't
actually shoot any scenes for the flick
together instead a clever editing and
dumb seeming betrayal of his family
allowed the two bold beefcakes to share
starring roles without actually sharing
a scene however in a rolling stone
interview in 2018 Johnson indicated that
the beef had been at least somewhat
squashed according to the rock himself
right now I'm concentrating on making
Hobson Shore as good as it can be but I
wish him all the best and I harbor no
ill will there just because of the
clarity we have actually you can erase
that part about no ill will we'll just
keep it with the clarity that's a little
harsh but by September of last year the
rock seemed like he was finally able to
put all the bad blood behind him Johnson
made an Instagram post thanking his
former co-star for all his support
Johnson said I want to thank brother
vain for your support of Hobson sure we
did it the right way we did it the smart
way and again
I appreciate your support and of course
all roads lead to one thing I'll be
seeing you soon Toretto
Johnson's reference to Diesel's
character in the series certainly
implies the Hobbes will be back to mix
it up with him once again but if so he's
running out of road that is going to go
to work
it has been widely reported that fast
and furious 10 will officially bring to
a close the series that Universal
Pictures is now referring to as a fast
saga considering that the finish line is
insights it doesn't seem like Johnson
would let a little thing like a
three-year-old beef keep him from
appearing in the final film of the
series look at the end of the day the
truth is there's unfinished business
between Hobbs and Dawn it's unfinished
well nothing has been officially
confirmed the rumor mill has gone into
overdrive reporting that Anonymous
inside sources insists that Johnson will
return for fast 10 it's also worth
mentioning that John Cena who will
appear in f9 as Toretto's long-lost
brother
has done a bit of blabbing to the press
about the possibility asked about the
likelihood of an onscreen showdown
between himself and Johnson Cena uber
confirmed that it was happening before
seeming to catch himself according to
Cena I will say this and man it's
amazing the parallels that fast runs
with double W E in fast Never Say Never
well we're certainly not going to be the
ones to say never bringing the rock back
into the mix for the conclusion of the
high octane fast saga is likely to yield
only one results the fastest most
Furious flick of the whole bunch
this time it ain't just about being a
fast
[Music]
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and TV shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the belle so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]